hmm a sweet gesture or a coincidence
Zendaya is the one at serving looks
she's the one to go for for this fans
are speculating that Tom Holland's
honoring his girlfriend Zendaya by
rocking a simple Z embroidered on his
pants it's great to have that support
and that love around you because you
need that you know the theory started
swirling after paparazzi photos of the
two surfaced online in one shot Tom and
Zendaya are out grocery shopping in his
hometown of London last week and spotted
on Tom's pocket is the initial of his
lady love then Tom was caught out on a
separate occasion last July sporting a
similar pattern I have no complaints
he's been photographed wearing different
pants that each have a z stitched onto
them seems like quite the romance
suggestion now at first glance one may
think he's wearing a particular brand of
jeans but internet users discovered no
design was found
[Music]
I am sweating now fans are piecing
together that Zendaya's openly discussed
her love for knitting in the past which
may explain the stitching on Tom's pants
who taught you to knit oh my my mom
taught me to knit well I wanted
something that was casual and cool well
one thing's clear Zendaya and Tom who
went public as a couple in 2021 are
going strong and through it all Toms
never shied away from showcasing his
love for Z even in the most subtle ways
I think Zendaya
showed up
[Applause]
that's her no no that's I want to see
what she has on can we watch is she
gonna walk down here
it's her let's watch
oh she's going in she's going in she's
going in she's going there
foreign